power uh I have no reason to think not um I mean
in some ways Trump looked like a more reliable
Ally Maybe but look at the speeches Biden and
Trump gave in the aftermath of this thing I mean
there's I haven't seen them oh I mean Biden's
I mean correcting for you know the evidence of
you know geriatric neurological problems Biden's
speech was was just a full Embrace of our allyship
with Israel and Trump's was this kind of deranged
self focus criticism of Netanyahu and I mean it
was just it was it was all about Trump Ian it's
uh I mean that is on brand yeah no butor but the
argument I think might be sorry to interrupt
that a trump was seen as tougher uh perhaps
more irrational which is not unhelpful in the
sort of situation and also he worked very hard
on the Abraham Accords right which which were
taking the Middle East some people would argue
towards a healthier Place yeah and I would agree
with that part um the Abraham Accords I think uh
it's just not it's just a non-factor for me I
think is this is going to H happen anyway this
will continue to happen it was unsurprising that
it happened the the details of its happening were
profoundly surprising given what we thought the
IDF was was capable of and and what was unlikely
to you know the specifics were were surprising
but um this will be recurring story of Our Lives
until frankly until the Muslim world has a civil
war with itself with its own extremists this not
it's it's it's not a problem we're going to
solve we need two billion Muslims to figure
out how to deal with their problem of homegrown
extremism in 100 countries yes I hear you I think
the source sorry to needle this but I think it's
important to flesh out I think the source of this
question I may be hallucinating is is you were
vehemently anti-trump and I guess what I think
people are asking is were you not wrong about
that because there's so many other liabilities
with Trump I mean in fact it's the similarity
to Trump and trumpism that sha that did much to
shatter Israeli society and seemingly soften
it up for this attack right it's in so in so
far as Netanyahu who a a lot smarter than Trump
and more sophisticated than Trump in so far as he
resembles Trump in so far as he was engineering a
similarly populist eruption of bullshittery in his
own Society um the divisiveness of all of that the
the untenability of all of that the the the lack
of pragmatism the taking the eye off the ball of
of the real threats to to Israel um you know it's
the similarities there are are are awful and and
in so far as uh we have a trump and trumpism has
a similar effect on our own Society um it repres
represents the same kind of opportunity cost I
mean you think of all the things we didn't get
done and will not get done for every moment we
spend dealing with the divisiveness of trumpism
and and the counter reaction from the left I mean
it's just it's just a massive opportunity cost so
no I think it's there's nothing good even if you
can find some local instance where Trump was right
about something uh and the Democrats were wrong I
mean he's he's totally right about the southern
border right I mean so that's a there's no in my
view there's absolutely no defense of having an
indefensible border we should know who's coming
into the country we should let the people in we
want in we should keep the people out we want to
keep out we should have obviously a sane and
compassionate policy with respect to refugees
build the wall I mean yes if the wall is the
best way to to secure that border then Build
That Wall right so Trump's right about that but
he's such an awful human being and his effect on
our politics is so toxic that we can't even that
that that half of our society has to treat that
completely San project as a form of racism because
they're reacting to the the the Golem of of trump
so we need other people even where Trump is right
we need other people quarterbacking those specific
decisions so what you're saying is you're Pro
trumps yeah exactly build the wall build the wall
exactly L lind's one we've touched on this
but they ask uh what is Eric's take on the
delus on the Deluge of pro Hamas protest after
the most recent attack in Western countries
well I tried to talk about I think when I
was on Rogan recently maybe on your show I
don't remember there's been a huge uptick in uh
open anti semitism and it's right on schedule I
mean I think that if you are monitoring what I'm
monitoring you're not that surprised by it you're
just you know what we knew is that it it's to the
Bone and so when people talk about you know black
and brown bodies or you know I don't feel safe
like there was a Spate of uh postings about I
don't feel safe as a Muslim you're like oh cut
it out it's a radical anti-semitic ideology of
Revolution and it's it's on schedule and it's
it's terrible that we've gotten here but in
part A lot of the well-meaning um left did
not understand that they'd gotten into the
ocean with a revolutionary current pulling them
uh along the beach and the they end up getting
out of the water very far away from their beach
towel they're not anywhere close to being liberal
tolerant um because in their attempts to say
well black lives matter and we care about this
they didn't notice who they were affiliating
themselves with and uh hopefully if you've seen
a charred body or severed limbs or shot up Port
tootes um you're making an intelligent decision
about what really matters to you and if you think
uh you know in the occupation free Palestine go
paragliders uh you're probably really deep in
it I I I you know I I hope that deprogramming
exists for you I hope that you really think
about whether you want to sanction um rape
torture and message killing and if that's your
thing then I guess well you know where you are
uh John Watson says uh could The Lads
ask Sam what he thinks his old friend
Christopher Hitchens would make of the current
political landscape particularly with regards to
gender identity which has essentially become
a new religion I think he would make exactly
what we have all made of it uh and it would be
a lot of fun to hear him talk about it but I I
think he I don't think there'd be any daylight
between him and us on that point I don't have
my but he'd be funnier and more cutting at
the same time it would be a lot of fun yeah
yeah World by wolf asks Eric pick
your dream president and VP for our
times well it's really hard because I think that
the current political landscape deforms everyone
who enters this I've watched this with with uh
the pressures put on Tulsi Bernie and uh R uh RFK
Jr um we keep getting a Fugu sort of situation
where there are lots of parts of the fish that
you like and there's some partition of the fish
that that's deadly and so we haven't had that I
I'm going to have to cheat on the answer to this
which is the Optics of the first Obama candidacy
is the substance we need in the white house um
but I haven't seen anyone with the ability to
run on this Gauntlet who's viable and so I I
just don't think that we have a situation in
which anyone is speaking in real terms I'm I'm
sorry to say it I can't see a single voice on the
viable political landscape that excites me and
the last thing I was excited about was Obama 1
and uh clearly I ended up buying a campaign that
governed in a very different form than the one I
expected Big Bob 886 says uh first of
all Sam I'd like to thank you as I've
been quite a fan of yours over the years
I watched many of your discussions and
debates and read and listened to a number
of your books and audio books my question
is this has the change from religious
values underpinning our society to
more secular values actually panned
out the way you thought or hoped it
would uh no although I'm not sure the the
the loss of religious subscription is is
the reason I'm sorry what what I'm What I
Hear in that question is that PE that the
moment you lose religious belief something
some religion shaped object is going to fill
that void and I I I don't actually think
that's true but you don't no you don't see
wokeness as a kind of replacement religion
no I mean I think that's it's um I it so
it has religious characteristics right so it
is so but uh first of all some of the people
who are woke are also religious obviously
it's not a perfect substitute but um I
think I mean there you know I it's hard to it's
hard to know what to make of the data and I just
know that you know I'm a I'm the existence proof
and many people I know are the existence proof
that it's possible to lose your belief in Santa
Claus and not replace it with something that does
all the work Santa Claus did the day before right
so it's you can you can find your meaning and your
aspiration and your motivation in in other ways
that have that run by a different logic once you
can but as we were talking about people basically
every but basically everyone I spend a lot of time
with can right so okay would you agree with me
that your your experience and the experience of
your highly selected friendship group I imagine
is not necessarily representative of the average
it's true but so then we just have to admit what
we're saying which is which rarely gets done which
is uh I don't need these crazy ideas you don't
need these crazy ideas but the the morons over
there are not going to figure out how to you
deliberately load did it with the motion so
let's take the EM motion out there are but that's
the subtext of this being claim not necessarily it
could be it could be that different people because
of uh many many different things genetics cultural
values their material circumstances their locus
of control over their own lives right which as you
get wealthier and more powerful and influential
changes uh some people are able to deal with the
things that religion traditionally has fulfilled
fear of death meaning purpose Etc that you and
to some extent I and Richard Dawkins I put the
same question to him when we had him on the show
about this some people are able to to get it from
things other than religion but if you take it away
from other people who are not wired the way that
you are who do not have the resources that you do
who for whatever reason they're not predisposed
to that way of thinking who have a greater fear
of death than you do for those people a set of
traditional beliefs that center around something
that you and I might agree isn't entirely true or
is entirely untrue you might say is valuable in a
way that it is not for you and your friends well
so what I will admit is that there are certain
cases where irrational dogmas cause people to
be to behave better than they otherwise would
there are certainly those cases uh and that's
good except for the fact that there are other
ways to get people to behave in those same ways
that are that are more valid and scalable and and
and have high more Integrity right so yeah it's
possible to go to subsaharan Africa and work in
a refugee camp because you believe the creator
of the universe wants you to do it and you're
saving souls for Christ but it's also possible
to realize that you just actually care about a
famine in Somalia or Ethiopia and you want to
work with Doctors Without Borders or whatever
and you're doing that actually based on caring
about human suffering and in a global sense
right so they're just one code is much better
to be running on your brain than the other um
and doesn't come with the attendant downside of
suddenly throwing this moral error of like now
we're Catholics in subsaharan Africa and we're
teaching the sinfulness of condom use uh even
when people are dying from AIDS and condoms is
the only way to prevent them from dying from
AIDS um Etc so uh there are better reasons to be
good than than religion tends to provide but I
would grant you that that religion does provide
those reasons for some people some of the time
my problem with religion is that it gets the so
much wrong that leads to to unnecessary conflict
and Division and and an opportunity cost in our
society this is certainly in the 21st century
with all all the opportunities in front of us
and it doesn't get the core parts right that I
would agree still are core like what are our real
spiritual opportunities like what what is how just
how good could human consciousness be moment to
moment how good can human life be moment to moment
and for that I do think there is a there there
there are these core experiences at the heart of
religion that gave rise to our religions perhaps
some more than others I mean again our religions
are different but I do think we need something
like a modern mysteries of elus where uh I mean
I'm I'm very I'm very mindful of the the the
errors we made in the 60s around psychedelics
but I'm very hopeful that a Renaissance of in in
research and interest in psychedelics um could
allow us to make to put certain experiences
certain transformative experiences and states
of Consciousness in reach for virtually everyone
and we need a cultural context in which to absorb
those epiphanies and talk about them that doesn't
make reference to our religious sectarianism or at
least doesn't make sectarian reference to our our
Legacy religions if you want to make eclectic you
know small C Catholic reference to you know
just the storehouse of religious literature
that's great you know there's no problem taking
the good parts even from the Quran uh to to make
sense of those those experiences but we just Rel
real religious sectarianism I think has to be a
deal breaker at this point I mean just it can't
it's just too costly so um I think it's good to
get rid of it in so far as we are getting rid of
it in the west that's good and the fact that these
these minor mon these minor monstrosities of of
things like wokeness and you know social justice
moral panics I mean even if they're drawing energy
from the the Advent of of a more atheism and more
more secularism um I think it's a bet I think
it's a price we should pay and and we need to
combat those forms of irrationality as well right
so I spent a lot of in recent years I've spent a
lot more time complaining about wokeness than I've
than I've and you know leftist moral panics and I
have organized religion and it's it's because
it's it's it's really uh in my in my immediate
purview it's it's been more costly you know I mean
it's it's V it's been vitiating our institutions
Eric what would you prefer physics or
music I have two
questions well jeez there's a tiny amount
of physics that's more beautiful than all
music okay so I'm going to go with that okay so
Mark Greg Sputnik asks what are the fields away
from quantum gravity that you feel are the most
important path paths for physicists to pursue
the standard model of particle theory was revealed
to be geometric in the mid 1970s and has been made
almost perfectly geometric by the end of the
80s the right thing to do is to ask why we
have three generations of fundamental fans with 16
particles per generation with a crazy Hig sector
with a quartic potential the accidents that is
of why this particular set of objects is without
question in my mind the most potent question in
all of physics and we abandoned it more or less
in 1983 when we switched to saying we're not
looking for a unified theory we're looking to
quantize gravity and so we reinterpreted and
in my opinion clearly misinterpreted what the
charge of physics was and the correct thing
to do is to ask why this particular universe
that we see ourselves confronting rather
than following the path to say what is the
general nature of quantum field Theory because
Quantum field theory was recently revealed uh
like linear algebra and calculus before it to not
have anything particularly to do with physics you
can't do physics without it but it turns out that
it's a general framework that governs many more
things that have nothing to do with the physical
world in which we live and so getting out of that
Quantum field Theory uh monomania and getting
out of quantum gravity monomania and substituting
with a question of why this particular
beautiful universe is the one in which we
live Charles C verbal says does Sam feel the world
is at its closest to World War
I it has been since World War
II I would defer to the the experts who
have really been watching this on that
I think I think it's still I mean you know
last week notwithstanding I think it's still
the opinion of most qualified people that
the Cuban Missile Crisis was the closest
moment but I'm not saying we're in a good
spot either it's it's I think it's our n
it should be our number one existential concern
uh followed closely by uh pandemic engineered or
otherwise so Joe asks Eric are are there any
fundamental questions in physics which AI could
help resolve um sure you could search for all
renormalizable field theories uh and try to do
an exhaustive search um I'm just going to make a
cautionary point I think that the idea of asking
AI to solve your problems with physics which
probably contains more leverage than any other
discipline has ever had in terms of the power
that can be wielded from Simply understanding
something it's as if you haven't seen a single
science fiction movie to prepare you this is
probably the dumbest console I've ever heard in
my life I cannot figure out what we're doing I I
I actually don't understand that last Point you're
saying asking AI to do discoveries in physics is
so dangerous we shouldn't be doing that or yes I
think that these are the last AIS that you could
consider you know the difference between chat
GPT and what is the chain GPT or where you have
it create the prompts to give you the next
you're playing around with things that you
don't understand before the attention is all you
need paper you could make the case that maybe AI
is very very dist I was listening to Sam in
my first meeting first day I met Sam we did a
podcast and Sam was talking about Ai and you can
tell where this is going he didn't have a time
frame I don't think anybody really understood the
large language model revolution in the Transformer
architecture and I think you're now so close
to something that could totally surprise you
um with particularly with emergent Behavior where
an AI will learn Bengali um because it needs to
without being told you should learn Bengali
now now um I would be very careful about the
idea that we're going to rely on AI to advance
our knowledge of physics we'll be back with Sam
and Eric in a minute but first we want to take
a moment to talk about our partners give send go
giv and go is a leading crowdfunding website where
thousands of people around the world raise funds
for business ventures medical expenses personal
needs nonprofits churches and funeral costs on
giv and go you can raise money for whatever you
need we've met the people at gifs and go and we
can tell you that they're absolutely aligned with
trigonometry on our approach to free speech they
don't just talk the talk they walk the walk unlike
other big tech companies they like us believe
that with openness and honesty we'll create more
understanding and ultimately more Harmony in the
world gifs and go is absolutely free to use with
other crowdfunding sites you'll pay between 5 and
10% of the money you raise give send go charge no
money at all to use their platform they believe
you should be able to keep all the money you raise
on giv and go you can choose to raise funds for
short or long-term campaigns whether you're in
the USA UK Australia or anywhere in the world GI
and go supports freedom of speech they won't cave
to the Mob and that's why we are proud to partner
with them starting a campaign on gien go is easy
and intuitive go to gien go.com today not raising
money for whatever's important to you and support
the people who support Freedom now back to the
interview uh Ramsey says that it's great to have
you back on the show and respect for that which
is nice um and I think alluding to the very same
point Al fight you naked says you have recently
made the decision not to speak to some people
who disagree with you why is that I'm not sure
who he might be thinking of I mean the so there
are people who I would not be inclined to talk
to I think Brett is one of them not because they
disagree with me but because I I think they've
behaved unethically you like there's uh no that
that if you're thinking of your brother that's
conflating two things they topics they they're
topics that I think it was irresponsible to
debate certainly in the middle of a a public
health emergency right um and certain styles of
conversation certain participants that I thought
was just never going to con Converge on use a
useful document to to export to to millions
of people so I felt it was irresponsible to
have certain conversations certain ways during
the pandemic there are certain other people who
totally disagree with me on lots of controversial
points who I will will talk to just because I you
know it's there there hasn't been any um breach
of Ethics no matter how much we disagree they've
always dealt with my side fairly or my beliefs
fairly then there are people who have gratuitously
misrepresented my my beliefs thinking they were
going to be scoring some kind of points against
me and they were scoring points against me for
Their audience right and those are people I'm
not inclined to talk to because I just don't I
don't want to reward W that kind of behavior I
mean certainly behavior that I have been fairly
careful not to engage in myself and when whenever
I've done it inadvertently I've apologized for
it um you know I never I never feel like I need
to straw man my opponent or much less lie about
their views in order to argue against them so um
but there's been a lot of incoming of that sort
uh toward me so there's there's some people who
used to be friends um who who yeah would not
be inclined to talk to but there are other
people who to again I'm not I don't know what I
don't know but like there there are people who I
disagree with a lot but I'll talk to them I mean
like you know Megan Kelly is somebody who like our
politics are not aligned but she's to my eye she's
always treated me fairly to a point that has been
uncomfortable for her in front of her own audience
knowing what her audience wants certainly in the
aftermath of the podcast we did and then the clip
that got exported to you know every every mind in
trumpet stand um you know the way she dealt with
that seemed totally fair and honest and so yeah
there's no I've got no hesitation talking to
her and there's a lot of people on that list
and there's a short list of people who consciously
created clickbait for Their audience very often
with my name in the title you know Sam Harris just
said something crazy and and um then they've used
that clip or some other clip you know even more
ridiculous Clips there was one clip made by the
same person who where it seemed I was saying or
uh you know the audience was led to believe I was
saying that I wish more kids died during coid
so I could have been proven right in my in my
paranoid views about Co um so if you're going to
do that of course I'm not going to talk to you and
if you're gonna if you're gonna dunk on if you're
gonna amplify that and dunk on that I'm not I'm
not inclined to talk to you s one question I have
about that is could you not I didn't understand
why you didn't try to do something with Brett that
was closer to correspondence chess where you had
a right to consult with experts given that you're
not a biologist right and or medical doctors and
the idea is that you don't have it live so that
you're you get you get broadsided but just decide
we're going to have a go back and forth of uh you
know 15 or 20 goor rounds and I'll be Consulting
people and you can be Consulting people let's
have the best version of that seems to me that you
didn't opt for an a non-standard debate so that
because of the opportunity cost because of how
much you know I would have viewed that probably as
a a month of work to do responsibly and I see no
reason to do it because your brother's disappear
down the this particular rabbit hole is is just
is not something that I felt I needed interact
with I mean I was it was it was getting thrust
in my facei so much that I had to I had to dis
interact with it enough to just to say I had to
kind of disavow it but the fact that he was going
to spend a hundred podcasts in a row worth of his
energy on that topic didn't shouldn't have meant
that I need could have set in to be whatever you
wanted I mean in other words even if if you
didn't end up having a debate at least if you
did that people would understand that you wanted
to have the Topline issues adjudicated and I very
much agree that you don't get into a fight or a
debate with somebody who's totally unethical right
because it's too dangerous well I I just think
I mean for me I I recently released a podcast
which I think you probably heard this like my
postmortem on coid um you know solo podcast and
for me the you know the the airplane analogy I
use there covers the sort of the the the framing
that works for me which is you know there are
moments where you want to really drill down
you want everyone to do their own research and
sunlight is the best disinfectant and let's just
talk about everything for as long as it takes and
there are moments when you really don't want to
do that where it's dysfunctional to do that where
other harms follow upon on doing that and you know
the analogy for me that covers it is that it's
like when you're getting on an airplane you know
or much less when you're when you're at 30,000
ft on an airplane there are lots of things you
don't want to talk about and and debate you don't
want you don't want someone to take a poll of the
passengers and you know ask questions like do we
still trust the pilots or or you know how do we
know those those engines were engineered correctly
and you don't want you don't want someone pulling
an episode of The Joe Rogan podcast which that
which has a engineer who says that he designed
the engines on the plane that you're now on and
it was always just supposed to be a concept engine
and it's irresponsible that they're being flown
and and and like just how much energy do you want
to give that when the reality of your situation
is you have to actually Land This Plane safely
right there's no alternative but to do that right
um and so this engine you actually have to rely on
this engine right now and what I what I thought
at the time and I still think is that uh we were
all essentially in a plane at 30,000 ft together
and we we we were having to figure out how to land
that particular plane given the engines we had
and we need so we you know we needed a we needed
a CDC that we could trust we needed an FDA that
we could trust we needed to trust the government
messaging with respect to what was actually
happening in the world and well s those are two
different points I agree with you that we needed
a CDC Etc we have one in so far as we didn't have
that that is something we need to deal with what
I what I feared and fear is that what has happened
is there's been such an erosion of trust in in
institutions and the layer of of conversation
we're having about about this in the aftermath on
social media is so dis functional and so and so
amplifying of mistrust right and misinformation
and disinformation that um we're just we're in a
very bad spot to reboot from I mean so so yeah yes
I mean absolutely we have to fix our institutions
are they as bad as your brother thinks they are
no way absolutely not right so I think he is a
you know uh he's just running a conspiratorial
operation that I think is is uh producing a lot
of Errors of thinking on his part um and that's
why I felt like I didn't have to interact with
it much but is is there a problem is he is he
right about some things of course is he going
to is he going to detect real conspiracies and
and perverse incentives uh sooner than then I
will maybe because he's constantly looking for
those things uh but I would agree that you know
yeah stepping back from the precipice of of you
know it's all [__] all the time all conspiracies
are true all the time everyone's evil everyone's
inen no no no I'm just that's that's the cartoon
version stepping way back from there yes we have
to we have to we have to align incentives we need
a you know a drug Discovery regime that actually
discovers good drugs and doesn't release bad ones
um we need all that and and I didn't see us
hashing it out in the middle of an emergency
on podcasts with obviously weird people like some
of the people your brother and and Joe platformed
I didn't see that as the method I understand and
uh we actually said we would finish now so we'll
finish all I'll say from my perspective is that I
think that heated moment is now over and I always
hate good people disagreeing and falling out
I hated what happened I'll say this in front
this is true of both me and Francis we hated what
happened with you after the interview with us and
I said this to you in an email uh the person who
clipped that is not a good person right uh so but
so they just to drill down on this the reason why
I'm sitting with you here is because I perceived
you guys to be totally ethical in how you handle
that moment and it was a conflict I mean that
moment worked to the massive advantage of your
podcast I mean it brought immense attention to
your podcast at the absolute reputational cost of
me right of center right so like a right of Center
that was a complete just witch burning of me but
I saw the way you guys handled it and I have no
problem with you guys I've never had a problem
with you guys so um so that's why we're talking
but Brett Amplified I forget this guy's name but
whoever the guy who made made that clip I think
he made the other clip I was talking about is it
Jack poob no no it's I don't even want to give
this guy attention he's he a pure I mean whoever
he is in reality Twitter has made him a psychopath
right and your brother locked arms with him just
without caveat and Amplified him as just this just
citizen journalist who has gone to school on all
the important topics and found all the errors in
my podcast and those clips were just it just it
was a pure smear Campaign which your which your
brother energized so that's I mean that's where
we that's where I am you know there's no I I
never did the analogous thing to your brother and
I wouldn't and I'm not sure where your brother's
head is now where he can can rationalize what
happened there but he's his buddies with a with
a complete lunatic and um what was amazing I mean
this is a much longer conversation ation about
how weird social media has made everything but
like when that 20 Megaton you know FAA was going
off in you know in your very much in your world
and blowing up your podcast in my like literally
nothing was happening in my world and in the
places I care about nothing was happening and
yet that was the first moment I could see how my
interaction with Twitter was just giving me you
know Pure Noise that was pretending to be signal
right now this and and I it's not that there was
no signal there and this is something you and I
have talked about a lot you know offline which
is um you know there's I I I basically based on
how I've designed my life and how I've designed
my my business I have the the luxury of being
of of not caring about certain things happening
to me online um but this was a case where it was
just like I was my life was like air gapped from
just like a mushroom cloud you know and it was it
was just so enormous and so non-existent where I
live that I just thought okay this is a this is
a hallucination machine you know and I've spent
12 years staring into it and it's um uh it's not
worth it so it's like the so the the outcome you
know the proximate cause of my getting off Twitter
was the aftermath of you know having gone on your
podcast and it's been you know apart from the
occasional feeling of like in this last week being
on the sidelines of a of a necessary conversation
uh which when I look 15 minutes later I realize
okay this is still just a digital sewer that I
don't need to be contributing to I have other
places to to make noise like you know on this
podcast um it has been like I mean as you we were
talking before we we started rolling it has just
been I'm embarrassed at what a upgrade of my life
it's been not to be on Twitter for the last 10
months or whatever it's been you're welcome I mean
no I mean it's it's completely inadvertent but
it's it's like it's it's been such a gift to not
be segmenting my life in you know dozens of times
a day looking at at the at completely I mean it's
uh I mean like it's like waking it's like waking
up from a dream where you just can't even figure
out how you got that confused you know and um it's
so yeah uh yeah thank you you gave me meditation
thank you for the absolute chaos you you dropped
into my life you gave me meditation I got you off
Twitter Fair exchange it remains to be seen
which is a bigger influence because it was it
was enormous all I wanted to say Sam is I think
it was a very heated moment the way people talk
especially online encourages fighting encourages
misunderstanding miscommunication Etc I think
you're a great person I understand you have your
concerns about the way Bret communicated about
Co he's also a great person as a human being
he's and I can tell you this from personal
experience because I've I gave Brett a piece of
very unhelpful information to him that I gave to
lots of other people that would require him to
take an ethical but very difficult decision and
he was the only person out of dozens that did
so I hope that one day there is a world where
you're sitting around a table you're sitting
on a show like or wherever it is that there is
understanding and Reconciliation I really hope for
that that's all I'm saying it may never happen and
it's entirely up to you and BR well to be clear I
I think I think Brett is I've all always thought
Brett was a a extremely ethical person I don't
know how he got so turned around as to think that
this jackass he's aligned with is a that his
ethics are well served by by amplifying that
kind of contribution to this conversation I think
that you're not if I may because I have the same
problem you have with this person um but but your
brother but strangely your brother doesn't have
the same problem with that with that person well
I was going to get to that which is I think that
Brett went through a catastrophe over Co where he
tried to make simple points things like vaccines
change adaptive Landscapes with respect to Fitness
computations that is a non-controversial point um
and to become I watch the system say oh we have a
problem somebody's disagreeing with the narrative
our beautiful Public Health uh narrative is
above your pay grade the only way to get you
out of this is to go after you as a human to
say you're you're promoting junk science you're
a Charlotte and you're a grifter etc etc and
Brett found himself suddenly you know because he
misstruck on every point which I don't think
he was um I knew that that was going to end
in Disaster by his structuring of it it did end
in disaster and what you're watching is somebody
trying to claw back their reputation after having
the full force of the US federal government um
find its way you know into the public sphere as we
saw in the Twitter files that you know government
is very keen that its Master narratives uh not be
taken down and so when you see you know I don't
know is the CDC talking about horse do you know
come on you're not a horse don't take horse paste
um he probably felt that he had very few friends
and allies who would fight side shoulder toosh
shoulder and so in part as the guy who popularized
audience uh capture is a something we all need to
worry about I can also tell you that isolation
and lack of friendship is a huge problem and one
of the things that I've been really upset about
is we have a very small number of people who
are strong enough to try to think in public at the
moment and we can't afford this infighting I agree
and I I personally think that you know I've said
to Brett Heather should never have gone after you
for Trump derangements syndrome Brett should never
have joined in you shouldn't have returned fire
but you did he did whatever that's the beginning
of this thing and you know now you've got this
super important thing that you should figure out
a way of offering something so that if and when
Brett declines to do your form of a structured
debate you're not the one who's denying them
the opportunity I'll just be very clear about it
there was a point where Sher re-recorded the song
I've Got You Babe with beas and Butthead and she
was so angry at Sunny Bono that she stuck it to
Sunny Bono in the re-recording of that song the
only problem is that that song was many people's
wedding songs that was people's song where they
got together and they got engaged who knows what
it wasn't her song necessarily to do with as she
saw fit because it was it was part of too many
people's lives and I believe that in part one of
the things that we owe our world is that we work
this [__] out if we have the opportunity to work
this [__] out and you know quite honestly Brett
has gone down a hole in my opinion um because
he's been forced to go down a hole so if that's
the question that you're asking I I think that the
issue is isolation and that's and just to close it
out I made this very clear statement that if I
find that any of my friends are guilty of murder
Mayhem rape who knows what as bad as it can be I'm
not going to be abandoning my friends and why am I
why do I make that statement one because isolated
people are dangerous we don't it's not safe to
have isolated people so you need to have friends
who keep showing up even when you're in prison the
other thing about it is is that then it becomes
very easy to get us to move away from each other
and you know the one thing Sam that I can tell you
is is that a lot of your friends on the sort of
the right hand side of of whatever this milu that
we're part of it's pretty clear everybody wants
to be in contact with you they want a better
relationship every you know everybody says I
miss Sam and whatever confusions they have you can
probably find that people want to want to figure
this out I mean I think people view you as a very
singular and important voice and I think it's a
it's a mistake to have all this Integrity where we
stop speaking to friends because they're all now
Beyond The Pale this time has been so confusing
that everybody has made terrible terrible mistakes
and the best of us have made fewer mistakes than
others but nobody has gotten away Scot free it's
just the quality of information we've been lied
to from too many different sources and we don't
have any institutions into which we can Retreat
and I I just I think it would be a good idea
for what's coming given what we've just seen in
the last week to try to figure out how to how to
get back yeah I mean not to air all of our dirty
laundry in public but to air some of it in public
um I mean all of the there's there's not a general
algorithm for this or you know it's just a this
is dependent on the specifics of a relationship
and the spe specifics of a person's behavior and
there are people who um I still don't understand
where their heads are at and I can't follow them
down the rabbit hole but there's no I don't
perceive any interpersonal problem between me
and that person BEC and again I don't know what
I don't know people are again they're captured
by their own audience they've got thousands of
hours of audio that they're putting out there
and I don't know what they've said about me but
for instance I said something about our friend
Majid on Josh podcast that uh I regretted because
I sort of I got sort of got walked into it and I
said you like he was telling me how crazy Majid
was and you know I I haven't F Majid's gotten
very conspiratorial and it's all planemic and it's
all like I I don't agree with any of it but I said
something you know however subtly disparaging of
Majid's whole project and the problem the ethical
problem was I had never personally reach I had
never had a personal communication with ma trying
to figure out where his head was at um so yeah I
so I apologized to mod I went on maer's podcast
and apologized to him talked to him for an hour
about a lot of stuff that I still don't agree with
you know I I can't explain where Ma's gone and
it's kind of similar to where where your brother
went um but I do perceive a difference between
people who like they're listen if I have if I if
if I have misrepresented anyone's position about
anything to their reputational detriment I'm just
I want I apologize for it and like I I do it with
with truly Bad actors I mean like Glenn Greenwald
who's just you know does not have an ethical bone
in his body uh though though every bone is in fact
sanctimonious and pretending to be ethical this
is a guy who when when I was 10% wrong about what
whatever his stated view was I apologize publicly
on my podcast right where is where every word out
of his mouth about me from him is a lie or a
half-truth calculated to paint me as a as a
dangerous Maniac so it's like you know it's it's
something that all I can do is be careful and
honest on my side but I have to notice when people
even some former friends are treating me uh with
with zero integrity and and they see absolutely
nothing either they think it's a symmetrical
relationship like we both got this sort of bad and
let's just bury the hatchet but they're not seeing
what they did so in the absence of Brett's
attack poodle like if the attack poodle went
away his his endorsement of the attack the
attack poodle went away I don't care I don't
care about the poodle I care about okay assume
that his endorsement of the attack poodle went
totally different situation interesting totally
yeah I'm glad we had this conversation I respect
you both immensely and Brett uh I don't agree
with everything any of you say a lot of the
time right that's how we are we're human beings
so I really hope there's a world in which that
particular thing gets patched up and lots of
other things get patched up the pandemic was
it sent everybody [__] mental MH it just
did we have to accept that everybody in some
way or another I hope we can get through it
I thank you both uh for coming uh for having
this conversation we appreciate you both yeah
and uh let's hope this one goes viral for the
right reasons yeah yeah inshah yeah wait
for the clips yeah thanks guys thank you
guys